We are taking calls at six one seven eight
three zero 47 50.
Let's go next to Ronald Reagan, who is on
the line today.
Ronald, what's going on?
Oh, hey, David.
How's the gone?
Good, how are you?
Good.
I wanted to say I really appreciated your
tone, the tone of you.
So I think that you are taking the threats
of what was staring down very seriously.
And which threat is that?
Shape them.
Well, what's coming in November and what's
to come in another four years if we don't
do the right thing?
Got it.
Yeah.
I mean, I think there's a lot of navel gazing
on the left and sort of like, you know, like
there's a time and a place I feel like for
another I'm some DNC lackey or anything like
that.
But it's just really frustrating, I think,
to see people treating this as sort of like
situation normal and it's not.
I do want to suggest I don't know if it's
possible to line up a week of shows or something
like that where you break down sort of the
battleground states and their electoral systems
and who's in charge and what those states
with the voting should look like.
Because I do think on election night and I'm
through afterwards, like we're likely to see
some irregularities and it would be good as
people are prepared for that.
I think that that is good, you know, I think
to be totally transparent.
I think a week of shows listing state voting
systems would be pretty bad.
I don't I don't think my audience will really
shift that.
Nearly two weeks would be even worse.
That would be twice as bad.
But what I will continue to do is to let people
know where it is that they can find out in
their state.
Where can you early vote?
When can you start early voting?
What's the process for voting absentee?
Can you drop off your absentee ballot?
That I will keep giving people the resources
to figure that out.
But I'm not going to do two weeks of shows
on that, unfortunately.
Well, all right.
Yeah.
We've come to a compromise.
I'm glad that we've done that fair.
Keep it.
Keep up the good work.
And one of my good friend who I mean, look,
you don't have to put this on your show.
You don't want to.
But who I met literally through the majority
report.
He's now he's now a David Pakman member.
And like a big fan of your show, he does love
me.
So that's huge.
So, you know, I don't want you to think it's
all antagonistic coming from the Reagan.
I love it.
All right, my friend, thank you for the call.
Take care.
All right.
We'll see if there's Ronald Reagan, not Reagan,
like the President.
Reagan like a ray, like a cathode ray gun.
As if if you can imagine that.